ask about Kanye real quick just cuz he's  on the record right and you know not  briefly he's a he maybe was going to be  on maybe a little more on the record at  least my reporting tells me nom  he's now cancelled his tour he got  hospitalized for exhaustion he went on  stage he say what a voted for Trump like  what do you make of that he's a friend  of yours yeah yeah he's my brother you  know I just uh it's difficult you know  because I love him you know that's my  brother I'm saying and I reached out to  him and I'm hoping that we just get to  talk you know and I just probably would  leave it there because I really care  about that dude and but his remarks for  something that requires here not having  a real serious discussion